So let us now return to our original example of these two stories and
see how the analysis we have done, this semantic analysis,
can help disambiguate between the two meanings of kill here.
So, first my background knowledge tells me that kill can have several meanings,
just like take had several meanings earlier. Kill can have
the meaning of causing the death of someone, or kill can have the meaning of,
to put an end to something. There could be other meanings of kill as well.
Second, my background knowledge tells me that when kill has the meaning of,
to cause the death of someone, it typically is a victim as well as an agent.
In this particular case, the victim is 25 people,
the agent is a serious earthquake. My background knowledge also tells me,
that when the meaning to kill is to put an end to something,
then typically it is both an agent that puts an end to something and
an object that gets put an end to. In this particular case,
25 proposals is the object, and the agent is President of Lower Slabovia. It is
this combination of background knowledge that allows me to infer the meaning of,
kill, in the first sentence as, to cause the death of,
someone. And kill, in the second sentence as,
to put an end to something. I hope you can appreciate the power and
beauty of this theory. But it is also important to point out that this theory
has many limitations. To understand some of the limitations of this theory,
let's go back to the sentence, I took the candy from the baby. In this sentence,
we inferred that took signifies stealing the candy from the baby. And in fact,
we had a large number of rules that told us how to make sense of
the word take by making sense of the word candy, making sense of the word from.
But as we look at increasingly large number of forms of the sentence,
the number of rules that we need starts exploding. So consider small variations
of the sentence. I took the candy for the baby. I took the toy from the baby.
I took the medicine from the baby. I took the smile from the baby.
I took a smile for the baby. They're all valid English language sentences, and
each one of them tells a story. As I look at more and more variations of this
sentence, I'll need to find more and more rules that can disambiguate between
different interpretations of cake in those variations of sentence.
In practice it turns out that it's very hard to enumerate all the rules for
all the variations of sentences like this one. Nevertheless, the story appears
to cover a good percentage of stories that we routinely deal with.